this is the Leica Q and it's the first
compact camera truly worthy of this
little red dot the QSF fix 28 millimeter
lens attached to an all-metal body and
it looks a lot like a smaller version of
one of like as classic M range finders
inside is a massive 24 megapixel sensor
and a quick processor both of which were
developed just for this camera it shoots
raw and JPEG and you can shoot either
through the electronic viewfinder or use
the bright screen and Live View mode my
favorite thing about the Q is just how
much you can make it feel like shooting
with a traditional light go when you
want to there's a smooth manual focus
ring adjustable frame lines in the
viewfinder and physical controls for
shutter and aperture but when you want a
run-and-gun
conveniences like extremely fast
autofocus and digital exposure overrides
come in handy the F 1.7 lens combined
with high ISO settings make it easy to
shoot in any lighting conditions and
there's also a macro mode that lets you
focus down to just seven inches the
images that come out of the camera
razor-sharp colors and shadows render
incredibly and things like color
fringing and than getting aren't
problems at all the touch screen is
better than anything I've seen on a
camera before but it still miles behind
what's on your smartphone and while the
menus are simple there's sometimes so
sparse that it's difficult to find what
you're looking for at four thousand two
hundred and fifty dollars the Q is
pricey for a compact camera but it's
still only about one-third the price of
a comparable Leica M setup if you're
looking for the like experience with
modern conveniences like autofocus and
don't want to pay the price of a new
Prius the Q is an outstanding choice
you